garcia gets the start here at minutemaid
park
shows wearing their orange tops tonight
looking to continue this four game
winning streak they played some of their
best baseball
of the season over the last 17 games
with that 13-4 record scoring a lot of
runs and the pitching staff
has done a good job with an era below
three during that stretch as well
the pitch hit hard and it's a fair ball
past first base gonna kick around in the
corner
goodwin trying to make two he slides in
safely head first
just ahead of the tag by correa that is
a double for brian goodwin
one and two to moncada
and juwan sends it out towards center
field and down
in front of straw goodwin will only get
to third straw deked him
they're at the corners with one out for
abreu goodwin at third moncada
at first garcia's pitch ground ball
base hit and to right right off the end
of the bat
and he scores goodwin with a bleeder
single and there is monkatta to third
one nothing sucks
swinging a miss big strikeout for luis
garcia
keeping a runner on third base now with
two outs picks up his first strikeout
altuve playing very deep out in right
field
3-1 from lamb he grounds right to jose
and he'll throw to first for the final
out
the white sox do get one on the abreu
hit
for the chicago white sox 11 starts this
season has a beautiful era at 1.89 a
whip
sub one 97 strikeouts already in 69 in
the third innings pitch
two and two from rodon to altuve and he
struck him out with a high fastball and
there goes
altuve for out number one and he bounces
one
to the hole at short backhanded anderson
and a pick on a throw in the dirt by
abreu
so the astros go down one two three our
score white stocks won
astros nothing five for 12 over his last
four games
222 on the year and he lines into center
for a base hit
that's nice beautiful swing on the
first pitch fastball at that
when he is ready for a fastball and
attacks it like that
oh he's going to put up good numbers
runner on the go swinging to miss great
throw by machete there's number eight
martine maldonado throwing out the base
runner zach collins attempting to steal
his first base of the year
one catcher gets another and there's two
outs in the inning
oh one pitch on the ground out two bays
there
two hits and a walk in the innings do
not hurt luis garcia
he has allowed five hits portrayals just
one nothing one nothing in chicago as we
go to the bottom of the second
inning julie gurio leads it off
penny struck him out low fast ball ends
goriel and four up four down for carlos
rodon
carlos correa with two outs and he
bounces to third fairball
picked up by moncada cross body throw
out at first and that'll retire the side
we're through two
our scores chicago one astros method
abreu their first baseman had the rbi
single back in the first inning
here's the o2 breaking ball did he go
yes he did checking with the first base
umpire
alex tosi and they ring him up garcia
now stretches
the pitch to lamb hit on the ground hard
pass the first baseman
into right randall will make
third the white sox in another situation
where they could score
here's the dangerous andrew vaughn now
off speed pitch line to left field and
that is going to be
caught brantley as that ball had good
carry but
the white sox strand a couple more we'll
go to the bottom of the third inning at
minute maid park
there are certain nights when guys come
back to the dugout
realize you are in for a challenge and
tonight appears to be one of those with
rodon on his game early
swing and a miss on a slider he struck
him out number three
for rodong
into center field goodwin on the move
and he is there to make the catch
perfect through three carlos rodon it's
one nothing socks
go to count here's the pitch and that is
strike three call
outside corner with the fastball and
there's one away 3-1 to anderson
it's this one high in the air toward the
line playable for mccormick tiptoes on
the warning track now
in on the grass and garcia has retired
four in a row
1-1 popped up by altuve right side
infield
and abreu will take it
10 up 10 down for rodon one out here in
the fourth sox lead one zip here's chas
mccormick
three and two he busted him with a
fastball 99.
man he reaches back when he needs it and
finds it michael brantley with two outs
pops it up near the plate it's
collins and he's got it in foul
territory
so we've completed four the astros do
not have a base runner and the white sox
lead this game
one to nothing you get the sense every
once in a while when something special
is kind of going on
one ball with two strikes with one out
there's a ground ball on the left side
that's gonna be the first hit of the
game
as jordan just reached out and touched
that one and sent it down the third base
line and the astros have their first
base runner
and carlos rodon just kind of shaking
his head and now
back to back astros have reached base
the astros with their first threat of
the game
here's the pitch that is hit to the
right side that's a base hit
gets down into right field and they will
hold yordon
up at third base so the bases are loaded
as the astros trying to break through
here with one out
another one two called strike three
slider was up straw did not pull the
trigger
that's out number two oh what a big
strikeout
they're ready to go and they're on their
feet the 3-0 pitch
hey that's upstairs not even close
a bases loaded walk for martine
maldonado jordan alvarez
scores and we are tied at one it's a
crazy game this game of baseball
hands together now for rodon runners
take off swing and a miss strike three
he walked maldonado to tie the game but
it could have been worse
but garcia ahead the count oh and two
one out we are
in the top of the sixth inning in a
one-one ball game
pitch from luis garcia and there's a
swing and a miss
one strikeout in each inning for luis
garcia with two outs here's the pitch
from the least guard see a swing and a
miss
and he got him seventh strikeout for
luis garcia
after five and a half the kick and the
two two-strike pitch swing and a miss on
a slider
he struck him out the 3-2 pitch hit in
the air to center field
goodwin will come in about three steps
and he'll grab it nice job by rodon
after that laborious fifth a one
two three sixth top of the seventh
inning 1-1 ball game white sox and
astros luis garcia back out there
he's been fantastic here's the 2-2 swing
and a mess he gets him
as he strikes out his eighth of the game
he has through
seven innings of one run baseball first
and second with one out for the astros
here it comes ground ball to short
picked up by
anderson flip to mendic relay in time
two
six to four to three and the sox get
out of the seventh with no damage done
brian stanek
who makes his 30th appearance of the
season one and one with a
3.9 era
two-strike count and the pitch is strike
three
call grondahl doesn't like the call
thought it was off the edge but that
is a good pitch by stanic for strikeout
number nine for the astros tonight his
first in the top of the eighth inning in
a 1-1 ball game and the pitch and a
swing and a miss and he got him
struck him out and we go to the bottom
of the eighth
great ball game going on admitted bade
park astros one white sox won ryan
presley taking over here in the ninth
adam engel batting here in the ninth
inning in a 1-1 game swinging a miss
he blew him away and that time left no
doubt
swaying and a miss got him with the
fastball up brian presley back-to-back
strikeouts two
away astros and white sox tied in one
swing and a miss he struck him out
ryan presley comes in and blows away the
side
in the ninth inning we go to the bottom
of the ninth here we go
bottom of the ninth inning astros only
have three hits tonight but they have a
chance to walk it off facing the young
lefty garrett crochet
the astros have the winning run on first
base with jordan alvarez coming to the
plate
here's the ball ripped down the right
side that's in for a hit it'll be extra
bases julie going around second headed
for third they're gonna wave him home
here's the throw newly slides in the
astros
walk it off jordan alvarez
the rbi double and the astros
win it 2-1